yeah hello and welcome to this video at
all the late start I didn't see the game
starting here okay the reverse scroll
cream hmm yeah III year this move d 5 is
interesting but the three is always sign
that the other side maybe has some idea
about this t3 okay and switch off my
mobile here ok if nitey to instead of
taking is that an accurate move or not
mm-hmm is there a possible way to
exploit it I don't really see itself
going to play normal stuff
hmm
jam l'exposition I we have made it quite
a bit of pawn moves it can't be could
backfire no it's a silly primal 95 looks
unlikely to happen okay so right so I'm
going to take and watch now maybe it's
hard to imagine that I should do this at
some point yeah okay now I can go F form
which is a debatable decision but I want
to have some play em even giving up some
squares yeah like you form
I think I'm okay it also makes the
bishop on c8 have some kind of IDM going
to g4 to f5 so he directly goes for some
central plane hmm okay hmm I wonder even
this is not so bad I wonder how he takes
him taking with them with the H pawn is
kind of why I known it leaves him also a
bit vulnerable due to to Queenie 8 and
things okay this one just Bishop g4 yeah
and come on let's let's use this tempo
to get the bishop out and here's one
case where it was good too dumb to know
that I don't have to worry about queen
bee three okay I could take now yeah and
I guess I do and now
the bishop he is making sure that Rob t1
is not possible I'm angling for Bishop
to b6 see just going d5 here or maybe
you know check and let's do that he
cannot take on c6 at the moment
okay they're just going to take it's
probably probably equal or is it getting
something won't be seven here or maybe
maybe is Bishop g5 it's not working with
this one so cheeking
hmm I'd estimated that the trial are
hurt whoa why is he offering a draw here
it's I don't get it
I'm overlooking something here I don't
get it quite
my threatening be seven which is kind of
annoying and I don't see anything great
iam no I didn't want to draw not sure
how to avoid it though ah come on I'll
Drive let's be practical yeah I think
I'm just clearly worse so I don't get
the draw offer but it was hard to
decline really I'm just losing b7 so
probably taking wasn't any good oh yeah
this is what the engine gives and equal
and then everything gets traded
something like that check yeah maybe why
this better here this is an engine line
well it probably probably I mean King is
open but nothing nothing special I guess
he made that move yeah they know it's
equal after Queen traded sherry
completely equal check check this is not
something that white can play for an
advantage I think he I had to do
something something else earlier this is
okay check yeah i can already stopped
him from making those mostly i would
have to get in i know this is not worth
analyzing really mystery check can you
can try to play for a loss here if you
like
yeah kind of a game in a game ok I'm
going to thank you him give sank you end
now we stopped examining let's do this
is possible yeah so let's have a quick
look down yeah it's a relatively normal
position for this yeah as I said that's
a debatable move but I wanted to get
some play give for cheeks gigs yeah
tempo all normal hmm maybe this isn't so
great and I should do this and go here
that looks better actually it's very
likely that i get the bishops traded and
this is really helpful and my looks are
connected let's a better move probably
but I should be okay ever should be six
is good enough check but here this is
not really good and I'm getting into
trouble it's also very hard here to
avoid the Queen trade he's got stuff
like this so Bishop g7 creature five so
i probably have to and something like
that it's really just the bond down not
quite sure why he offered to draw yeah
that was lucky I guess thanks for
watching